nous parlons d'un énorme potentiel pour des
millions de personnes
notre thérapie permet au cerveau de se
réparer nous l'appelons le remède
je veux que
vous commenciez à tester sur les chimpanzés dès que possible
nous testons un sujet je veux m'assurer
qu'il est stable
j'ai conçu le 112 pour la réparation
mais césar est allé bien au-delà de cela,
vous voulez dire une intelligence accrue les
compétences qui dépassent de loin celles d'un
homologue humain c'est faux bien
cela fonctionne
et qu'en est-il de césar où se situe-t-il
dans
la propriété de la compagnie de ce navire, il n'a pas
passé de temps avec d'autres puces
ils  n'êtes-vous pas des gens que
vous connaissez essayez-vous de contrôler des choses qui
ne sont pas censées être contrôlées
ils sont
contaminés abattez ces singes
vous n'avez aucune idée de ce à quoi vous avez affaire